no perché non solo capaci a farlo
youtube e ray non ci avevo il mio phone
i tempi aspetta niente non metta a fuoco
fuoco grazie gentilissimo vi faccio un
mega riassunto sono sponsor della
division iii per il prodotto nuovo che è
uscito mio fan c'è anche il mio tab che
sarebbe la versione tablet che sono
prodotti che costano molto meno di un
telefono normale o di un tablet normale
perché sono diretti ad un pubblico più
piccolo ma comunque sono prodotti veri
cioè che funzionano il telefono questo è
un telefono vero e allora perché siamo
qui oggi a mio caro gianpi tex habitech
si permette di fare video con di bestia
non so perché ogni data non lo previsto
però conoscendo la persona e sapendo che
mi odia a morte avrà parlato malissimo
di me quindi oggi facciamo a reaction
iphone hicks versus mio von 1.200 euro
verso 1100 non sa leggere il vino non
vuole essere un dissing affari gen
telefono non è di fa vj ma è della
lisciani fa vj ha fatto lo sponsor e
basta due non mi hanno pagato purtroppo
scontrini su scontrini o a 20 euro basta
per un cpt apocalypse
beh direi che possiamo cominciare
comunque la cosa volevo dire è che
quello era il mio microfono vecchio
adesso c'è quello nuovo perché io faccio
lo sponsor degli sciami e tu no perché
qui abbiamo il mio phone con la
fantastica copertina di fa vj spettro
non sai zio quanto ci abbiamo messo ha
fatto la foto perché mi son dovuto mette
così ma sacco di volte perché veniva
male non vengo bene in foto radio mi
photoshop e non ci sono neanche in sé in
questa foto se photoshoppati falso e
oggi andremo a fare il confronto con
l'iphone 10 auricolari inclusi fermo 5
pollici hd
ps 720 per dire va bene andiamo avanti
direi di non perderci in chiacchiere ci
tocchiamo un hype della madonna
soprattutto perché ho speso 150 novembre
25 mila mi piace per questo video su
builder spett
ero preso dal video perdonami se non
l'ho fatto prima gianpi da e questo è un
telecomandino praticamente che mi
consente forse di scattare le foto
questo modo tarlo qui perché sono
curioso quando tu c'hai l'asta dei self
i non ci arrivi a che calava centri come
sa è il telecomando perché fa vj
telecomando
la fantastica ma un po da ragazzo la
fantastica vanto dal bar da pulsante
sapete che io quella lampada non cielo
ed eccolo qui il mio folle che viene
fornito già con una cover protettiva
trasparente che andrò subito a rimuovere
occhiaie cazzo veloso paragone con
iphone 10 come dimensioni direi che sono
pressoché identici ragazzi sono uguali 6
forse dicendo che le nostre dimensioni
sono uguali gianpi tech
niente male allora dài il touch non è
male il form factor nemmeno fine che
anche ci siamo la il wifi funziona
aspetta aspetta già prima non c'era
primo tratto di strada adesso che hai
detto stava grazie di aver elencato il
fatto che è un telefono effettivamente
funziona abbiamo chiarito e vi dirò che
la qualità del display non è niente
niente male
gianpi la finiamo per favore per
cortesia l'altro ciancio un'app di
famiglia e gli incredibili e voglio bene
il caffè che beve gianpi the queen ferro
giambi il caffè che bevi d'ebrei o ci
sono tutte le acque tra cui anche un'app
di fa vj carapia l'app di famiglia ma un
account per cosa perché in quella caro
gianpi si accede al mio canale si accede
al mio canale se qualcuno per caso
riuscisse a trovare password e mail di
quella peli potrebbe fare quello che
vuole e proprio l'accesso e per entrare
devi mettere la tua mail e come password
gianpi te devi mettere la data del primo
giorno
qui ci siamo incontrati non te lo
ricordi vero primo giorno che ci siamo
incontrati gianpi e io non dimentico gli
amici tu sì tu sì da notare che la prima
cosa che manca nell'iphone e l'app di fa
vj quindi il punto a sfavore ce l'ha già
in partenza però effettivamente no che
succede nome partita pubblici gianpi
tech non si monetizzano i video branded
o ragazzi eccoci qua mi sono legato
praticamente no no giampi no che ci ai
miei video da ricordavi la data ma io
pensavo di sono stato sfiduciato scusami
non mi modificare i video di fa dj per
vedere forse il video che si spera come
diventare youtuber apri adesso stiamo
aprendo famiglia e se stai guardando
questo video il mio sfondo supera gli
standard o fa schifo
perché hai una tenda se non fossi nello
studio ci starebbe a tende perché le
tende esistono però ci sono i pannelli
coperti dalla tenda perché a seconda
cosa già gianpi perché ci sono i fiori
in basso a sinistra ed all'inizio del
video che li sto guardando un ok tante
avanzi tu però perché hanno ragazzi vi
dirò power bag ci si è scaricato andiamo
ad aprire chrome os x slim finalità
bellissimo gia perche la versione
desktop di youtube e non è niente niente
male
grazie grazie e basta bastati è che
tutto quello che è che vaste tutto hanno
trovato un altro top è finita la poca
l'ip si monetizza prima di natale è
repubblica repubblica.it homepage
andiamo ad aprirli contemporaneamente
vediamo quale sia per prima 321 via
ovviamente non stiamo qui guardate sia
aperto praticamente molto in fretta
perché non aspetta che sta warda
lunghissime da nessuno e ho perso una
parte sarri non l'ho comprato perché c'è
fa vige in copertina perché non me ne
frega niente no non è vero perchè dici
così solo per me solo perché ero così li
vale tutti i soldi che spendi gianpi
solo perché ci sono io tutto resta il
relativo non dire bugie per cortesia
vabbè ma a parte questo comunque già
pitt siamo alla fine però una cosa è
successo funziona questo è figo è una
figata vela funziona allora che si
poteva fare l'avrebbero fatto mai finto
spero di aver kicked aiutato un po
stupido perché non so bene cosa avrò
scritto nel titolo però faccio finta di
essere me l'ha presa tanto magari faccio
più click qua fa male qui io lo straw
fair che già effettivamente io lo
stopper che gianpi te che ha fatto
questo video lo so io perché tempo fa io
feci questo aveva visto recentemente un
video di gianpi tecnologico sia piccola
ci vantiamo
tipo avanti gianpi tech degli occhiali
nuovi tuareg a degli occhiali grazie
allora tutti 6 offeso ti sei offesa hai
fatto questa cosa non si fa
non si fa comunque ragazzi io vedo che
si è beccato quasi un k di dislike non
li merita in questo caso c'è stato
simpatico da me già adesso a parte gli
scherzi via che su faccio serio sul
serio sul serio sul serio io e gianpi te
ci conosciamo da una vita lui fa ironia
e io faccio ironia sull'ironia quindi
questo momento io sto organizzando un
casino il male non esiste in queste cose
quindi tranquilli nessuno sta rompendo
il coccige a nessuno e io lo fossero
veramente contento che già perché abbia
fatto questo video spero che dato che
l'hai comprato spero che lo userà i non
solo come tagliere sotto la gamba del
tavolo per tenere il tavolo fermo uso e
ricordati che se la dentro ci sono i
tutorial su come diventare youtuber io
un occhio ce lo darei a scherzare
facciaroni anch'io ma noi ci vogliamo
bene questa è una cosa che nessuno sul
web capisce tra di noi quando ci
parliamo siamo super pacifici quindi
smettetela di andare contro a gianpi che
poi ha fatto questa cosa io sono
veramente sono
mi è piaciuto un sacco il video ne sono
sincero gianpi tech io ti adoro lo sa lo
sai
l'unica cosa leva ai fiori per cortesia
perché non ha senso per il resto
ok però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi e mi
piace anche l'iscrizione sono sapersi
iscrivetevi e noi ci rivediamo ad un
prossimo play da nel prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]